okay we're jumping around a little bit
so we talked a little bit about elon and
mars and space
but let's uh let me jump back to a few
questions that folks had
i have to kind of bring up some
debunking stuff because i think
not the actual idea not the actual facts
of the debunking
but the nature of the true believers
versus the debunkers
hurts my heart a little bit because
people are just talking past each other
but let me kind of bring it up
uh mick west i've
just recently started paying attention
just in preparing to talk to you about
this world and nick west is one of the
better known people who kind of makes a
a career out of trying to debunk sort of
he's a
his natural approach to all situations
is
that of a skeptic i think it's it's very
useful and powerful especially for me
coming from a scientific perspective
to take the approach he does it's
valuable and
uh i think no matter what i think
there's i
hope that people quote unquote true
believers
are a little bit more open minded to the
work of mick west i think it's quite
useful and brilliant work so let me ask
uh here's a bunch of videos a bunch of
ideas
where he kind of suggests possible other
explanations of the things that were out
there
he has some explanations of the things
that you've seen
uh in the um with the tic tac like with
your own eyes like
he says that uh it's possible that you
miscalculated
the size and the distance of the thing
and so on when you were flying around
i don't fight that as uh i mean maybe
you can comment on that
person let me do it right now sure so
because that comes up like how
how did you know it was about 40 feet
long i go
okay so 16 years flying against other
airplanes
know what stuff looks like you know i've
looked down on things so if i know i
know here's the known things i know when
we saw the tic tac i was at
20 000 feet fish right around there so
when i look down
i know what a hornet looks like looking
down on him because i've done it for
all those years i mean i got a good idea
so that's that's why i said 40 feet
because it's about hornet size
so and as i go around you you get to the
point where you have to be able to judge
distance when we fly out of experience
and you can tell if something
small or big you know um so i would
argue the fact of
you know peer experience there's you
know
professional observers which is what
we're actually trained to do
um and having done it for so long
no it was and everyone came back with
the same thing they're like yeah i was
about size of hornet
from a human factors perspective how
often
in your experience of those 16 years
do you find that eyes what you see
is the incorrect state of things so like
how often do you make mistakes
with vision you actually you make vision
issues a lot because you're and the sad
part is your brain believes what your
eyes see
we are actually trained to do the
opposite of that especially when you
instrument fly because your brain and
eyes can tell you one thing
but you got to trust your instruments
let's go back to landing at night so
your eyes do you do that yeah land your
eyes assume
that the runway and your brain assumes
that the runway is
fixed but you know that the runway is
moving so if i try and do stuff
visually i would you die every time not
every time but you die close to every
time trying to land on a boat
so we actually use instruments which are
counter to your brain so
and there's actually all kinds of things
that we go through in training
they have this thing i think they still
use it it's called the msdd
multi-spatial disorientation device um
or the spin and puke it looks like a
giant
carousel and you're in these little
modules and when you get out you think
the thing goes really fast and they can
you can make yourself think that i'm
descending or climbing but you're
actually only going around in circles at
a very slow rate as fast as a human can
talk but as they spin you around in a
little sub thing
and slow it down and speed it up your
body does this and you you know and then
by visuals of showing you like they can
spin it sideways to the outside wall
but they can show like lines that are
they can make the line stand still
because they're moving the same velocity
they can move the other way and you'll
think you're screaming
you see it in amusement parks all the
time
you do all that because it gives you a
sense of the a but you're really
not doing you're sitting there so we get
trained on all that stuff so if you
if you want to look at it and go well
you're you're disoriented or this i bail
i'd argue going no i'm not because
you know when i'm flying the airplane
even as i'm looking at the tic tac i've
got a heads up display that tells me
what my airplane's doing
so i've got i know what i'm doing i can
look outside i've got a sense of what
i'm doing but i'm also looking inside to
cross check of what i'm seeing is in
reality what i'm doing
you actually your brain gotten good at
combining almost
adding extra sensory information you
have to you have like supervision
so you're combining what you're seeing
and adjusting what the sensors what
you're calling the instruments you're
giving you
and that that in turn is a loop that
adjusts
the perception system that like that
that adjusts your brain's interpretation
of what you're saying yeah you'd be
amazed at how good so here's
here's another example so if we go out
over the water so there's no land in
sight
and we're gonna fight so when we fight
you know two airplanes we're gonna
dogfight as an instructor
and i was for all most of my time you
have to come back and you have to
recreate it so we call it drawing arrows
so you have to recreate that stuff
so you get pretty good at going you know
like i would take off and say all right
we're starting heading
due east uh and i know where the sun is
at
because in the short couple minutes
we're going to fight the sun's really
not going to move much it's going to be
an irrelevance so now i know that the
sun
is at you know let's just say 195
degrees
right so i'm starting going east and
it's actually be down off my right hand
side
so now i know as i'm fighting because in
the water you don't have any reference
like oh i passed land i passed like no
you don't
you can't use clouds because clouds do
move but you got to come back because
you go here's where i started and then
you when as soon as you end you go all
right i ended heading
355. and then you recreate the turns and
the amount of turns and use the sun
relative so you can create this entire
battle that went on with arrows so you
can come back and debrief the guy that
you were teaching
on exactly what happened and you get
really really good at that
so when you come up and go well dave how
do you know you were at six o'clock and
he went around and he came up here i go
because i'm trained to do all that and i
take all the notes
while i'm flying you can do it and but
usually it's you memorize it all
and you get done and then you re you as
soon as you're done you knock it off you
look at the other airplane you get set
and you start writing all your notes
down
yeah and you're writing it really fast
on your card and you go out the stack of
cards and you stick the new one on your
knee board card so you're ready to go
and here's the next setup
um it's kind of it's in some way
similar to what uh like at the at the
highest level
chess players do i mean you're
i mean they they they recap the games
but the the richness of the
representation that they use
and remembering like how the game's
evolved
it's not like it's much richer than the
actual moves
it's like these a bunch of patterns that
are hard to put into words like
like all the richness of thinking
they have about the way the game evolved
it's more like instinctual from years
and years of experience
so they try to put it into words but
they really can't it's
it's just not i understand that it's
because for us
if we don't come back with anything then
there's no learning to be had right
because the whole thing is
the debrief when we get back and we talk
about that's really where the learning
is
um and it's the same thing if you want
to go back to chess you know when you
start off
you try and learn because you're
remembering what you're doing if you
play against someone i'm always a big
place
play with someone better than you that's
how you learn if you're constantly
beating people you're not learning
anything you're just learning that
they're not good and you're better
when you when you challenge yourself
against someone that is going to
is better than you you learn so i
learned how to fight an airplane
with uh he's actually one of my best
friends
we'll call him tom i won't give his call
sign because i don't even
so tom took me out and taught me how to
fight because tom
had just left hopkins he was the the the
training officer top gun which so
that's the guy yeah the training officer
is the main guy at top gun
so tom was a training officer top gun so
tom when i learned because i come out of
a6 and we really don't fight because it
was a bomber
so i get in f-18s and i want to learn
how to fight because it's a whole other
side of the mission it's the f
and f fighter attack the f a-18 is
fighter attack so
i had to learn how to fight so now i got
one of the best fighter pilots in the
world
who's going to teach me how to do it and
he did and i would
do something and then he would go i'd
get to a situation where i had never
been and then i would go well i'm gonna
do this and then he would
destroy me and he would come back and go
here's why you don't do that
and then i would take that knowledge and
i would put it in my little basket of
tricks
and over time because you know no one
walks out into that world i don't care
how gifted of an aviator and go i
i am the man yeah or the woman i'm it
yeah
no it's a learning process and so for
all those years you've gotten good so
i mean so
what are the chances that your eyes
betrayed you
when you saw the tic-tac
low zero well
i mean i'm not zero so okay 90 yeah i am
99.9
so 0.1 my eyes deceive me but remember
if it deceived me it had to deceive the
other four people so the percentage is
even lower
yeah look up well i i don't find that
that particular debunking case that you
saw but i'm glad you put it
you um you said those words out loud
so for me from our perspective uh coming
into this world and looking at it
i'm a little bit more skeptical
so your eye account i think is the most
fascinating story
and that uh i think
uh that's inspiring to me and should be
inspiring to a lot of scientists out
there
on so many levels just like we said in
the engineering level that maybe there's
propulsion systems we can actually build
that can do
some crazy amazing stuff so
it's a at the very least intriguing and
at the best
inspiring i just want to say that but on
the video side
it's like it's uh
the videos for the flair video
the go fast and then the gimbal video
they are only interesting to me
to me in the context of your story
like without that they're kind of low
resolution
it's like it it's easier to build a
debunking story
to be skeptical so it's just where i'm
coming from maybe you can convince me
otherwise
but so to bring up mick west one more
time
he looks at the flair video and he says
that
one of the most amazing video uh parts
of the flare video for people haven't
seen it
is at the end of it the
the the tic tac flies
or appears to fly very quickly to the
left
off the screen off the screen and what
midwest says
is uh that it you know midwest probably
others
that the way to explain that
is the tracking system like we said this
vision based tracking
simply loses the like the object
the tracking loses it and so
it simply allows the object to
float off screen because it's no longer
tracking it
so i find that at least a plausible
explanation of that video looking at
your face
you do not so can you maybe comment to
that
uh to that debunking uh uh sure aspect
so it's funny how people can
extrapolate stuff who've never operated
the system no for sure and that's like
me
going because i'm a big formula one fan
you know that's like me going oh my god
louis what were you doing you could have
done this with the car and you won the
race right you know and lewis hamilton
right now is
you know defending world champion
two-time he's four-time four-five-time
world champion but
um that would be pretty stupid to me to
try and tell lewis hamilton how to drive
a car
um or a matter of fact anyone driving a
formula one car
so i i can't tell you how many times
i've watched you gotta remember when we
looked at this thing
when when chad came back with the video
we sat there and watched it i mean i
can't tell you how many times i've
watched it off the original tapes going
all right right all right let's look at
this
um you know because you can look and see
where the you can see where the airplane
is going you can see if it's looking
left or right and if you actually watch
all that stuff it doesn't do that it
actually
when the vehicle starts to move the bars
the tracking gate starts to open up and
the people at raytheon could probably
add to this because they built the pod
the tracking gate will start to open up
and and but the thing
when it leaves so fast off the screen
the pod can't move fast enough it has
gimbal rates on how fast that thing can
move around because there's another
theory that
oh the pods looking forward when the pod
passes underneath the airplane so if i'm
looking at you and you pass underneath
me as
does this the ball will actually flip
around to kind of finish off
and it'll it'll it swaps ends because it
has you know it's a gimbal
it can't just it's not free-floating um
but there's a theory on one of them oh
it's here and it flipped over it doesn't
do that when it's looking out in front
it stays like this
so yet another another debunker who
doesn't know this so
you know and mick has had several
theories on other of some of the other
videos like one of them the go fast as a
bird
and jeremy corbell actually did a nice
job of saying no it's not because
he's on he's on black hot so the white
object is actually colder than the ocean
that's flying while birds aren't colder
than the ocean they'd be dead
so the gimbal video to comment on
the amazing aspect of that video is the
rotation the apparent rotation of the
object that
is something that is not
possible to do with systems that we know
of
and make west suggests that a flare
like reflections or whatever can explain
no because what mick west doesn't see is
so when they take because i've talked to
the
one of them actually i work with so i
know him i know i talk to him all the
time
so uh and it's his best friend actually
shot the video
one of his best friends for the giveaway
video they get moving both of them
the go fast and the gimbal were shot by
the same person okay
so uh and they were in each other's
wedding so that's how well they know
each other
okay so what you don't see is
so the airplanes are flying still super
hornets but they have the apg-79 which
is the new
phased array radar that's made by
raytheon things incredible okay
it doesn't usually if it's if it's out
there and it sees it it's real
so at first they thought they were ghost
tracks when they started seeing stuff
and then they actually threw one of the
targeting pods out there
well the targeting pod there's a heat
signature and you go hey dot heat
signature something's there
it's real it's not you're not picking up
some extraneous things so
what you see in the gimbal video of the
thing and it rotates and you go holy
[ __ ] look at that thing it's just
sitting there and it's in the wind and
it's going against the wind
why it's doing this you know someone
goes oh it's an airplane now if an
airplane does this it's eventually going
to start to change aspect because it's
in a turn
this thing doesn't change aspect it just
rotates right
the other thing that you see when you
talk to them is so they're on their
radar
there's an object that they identify as
their number one priority or their
launch and steering
so when they designate that that's where
the targeting pod is going to look
that's what you get in the gimbal video
there's five other i think it's five
they're kind of in a v you know like a
geese would fly
that are out in front of it and they're
actually coming they're out in front of
it and they actually turn
on the radar and go the other way while
they're filming the gimbal video
which it's i know uh ryan has come out
and talked about it
but when you see it you go you know if
you take it in context because you go oh
it's just the video
well if you take the video with the
radar going no there's actually other
things out there because
there's at least 60 people that have
seen these things on radar
off the vacates it was it actually
became
i called a buddy mike who was running
the wing at the time the fighter wing
i said dude what are you guys doing
about this he goes well we got a no tam
out which is a notice to airmen which
means there's these objects out there
in the warning area so anyone can you
can fly a cessna through the warning
area it's all the warning area tells you
that there's
high military traffic and training out
here it's probably best not to be here
but there's nothing that prohibits you
from going in there um
so these things have the right wherever
they're from or whatever they are
you know because people are like are
there balloons well balloons float
balloons don't sit in in 70 knots of
wind and stay in the same location they
don't say
they had an airplane because there was
two there's the gimbal thing that's a
pretty big object
there's also they talk about it looks
like a cube that's inside of a sphere a
translucent sphere what's that
transparent how is that
and i've heard you hit them so that's
another
that's one of the biggest another
biggest account it's like almost hit a
plane
uh uh something that appeared to be a
cube in a translucent sphere what do you
make of that
again you know what i mean that
that's that's the most dangerous you're
right the biggest frustration is when
you do that you go okay
so this thing passed between two
airplanes and it was i think it was
like 100 feet or something like that if
the airplane had almost hit it
so they do is they come back and go hey
i had a near midair would you have a
near midair with
this floating beach ball with this cube
inside of it and you go huh
you know so they send out a no tam again
and they they do a what's called a
hazard report that says hey there's
these objects out there we almost hit
one
you know and that gets sent off to the
naval safety center um
[Music]
what was done i mean what are you gonna
do you can you know catch one go out
with a giant net and try and bag one
you don't know because they've seen them
they've picked them up like hovering on
radar and then all of a sudden they're
traveling at really high rates of speed
so
you know what i'm gonna do what yeah
what are you gonna do
you